here in California were going to focus
on the politics in the nation's most
populous state in a moment I'll talk
with California Republican gubernatorial
candidate John Cox but first chief
correspondent Jonathan hunt tells us why
the top Democrat in the race may
actually support the top Republican in
this primary it takes courage to make
real change
that's Gavin Newsom and lieutenant
governor Gavin Newsom holds a
comfortable lead in the gubernatorial
race going into the June 5th primary
which on the California system will send
the top two vote-getters into November's
runoff regardless of party affiliation
President Obama called him one of
America's finest mayors
the race for the second general election
spot appears to be between former LA
mayor Antonio Villaraigosa who has not
been formally endorsed by President
Obama but whose backers know an
association will play well with
Democrats in California and Republican
John Cox a San Diego businessman whom
President Trump recently endorsed via
tweet saying John Cox is the man he'll
be the best governor you've ever had the
latest poll has via Ragosa and Cox in a
statistical dead heat with Newsom
comfortably ahead but also with 39
percent of voters apparently undecided
taking thousands in illegal gifts from
special interests if his ads are
anything to go by attacking via Ragosa
while emphasizing Cox's conservative
credentials for Republican voters John
Cox danced with Donald Trump and the NRA
Newsom would seem to prefer to face a
conservative Republican than a fellow
Democrat in the final vote the Vera Gosa
campaign describes Newson's approach as
cynical and says he will quote do just
about anything to get elected including
selling out his own Democratic Party for
Newsom himself the calculation seems
fairly simple Bret defeating a
Republican in the general election here
in what is still largely liberal
California will be easier than taking on
another Democrat as
stingrays and obviously general is a
different picture than primary Jonathan
thank you